there's no film series as as motivating
to as many gym goers as the rocky
franchise of every gym rat I know
there's not a single one who doesn't
love the Rocky movies the film's no
doubt inspired countless numbers of us
to get into physical training in the
first place and even outside of the gym
the rocky soundtrack and montage have
been synonymous with training to get
better at anything I have the tiger is
part of our cultural lexicon now gonna
fly now plays a very parody and
inspirational video count the sport
films have ripped off the rocky formula
from Karate Kid through to the warrior
and it's one that works at this day as
seen with the recent success of the film
Creed what is it about these films that
makes them so motivating inspirational
why do we respond to the rocky as a
character so much we've discussed dragon
ball now it's time to dive into the true
master class in motivation well first of
all there are some obvious reasons
starters it helps this is a film about a
very strong guy getting even stronger
and Stallone is an epic shape for a lot
of these films it also doesn't hurt that
the music has a driving beat and a war
on guitar or the montages find a way to
convey long training regimes over a
short period of time in real life we
need to spend months or years training
to see the results in Rocky films we can
get a glimpse of what that
transformation will look like if we keep
putting in the hard work the montage
also works cuz it manages to match the
images on the screen with the music so
perfectly tracks like training montage
by Vince Nicola managed to continuously
one-up themselves all the feats on the
screen become more and more impressive
it's all pay off with multiple emotional
climaxes in a very short space of time
it's no surprise that this gets you
pumped this is perfectly at the timaeus
in rocky 4 which is basically one long
music video there's also a hefty dose of
machismo on the screen
[Music]
seeing Apollo and rocky square off as
arrivals brings out a competitive spirit
in all of us and the desire to train
harder in order to be better
I loved the scene at the end of Rocky 3
where they set up a private match just
to decide once and for all who the
greatest fighter is that film in its
direct sequel in particular all about
the Warriors code and topics like
fighting fair and revenge opponents
square off in the ring talk each other
down and build the suspense for the
impending fights
it's like Dragon Ball Z but with a
little less screaming there's another
way in which the rocky series is
symbolist Dragon Ball Z - and that's the
way that both series followed their
protagonists across a large portion of
their lives I can't think of another
prominent film series that's so episodic
one doesn't count there's too little
continuity between the incarnations but
with rocky we encounter him as a
washed-up bum in his late 20s or early
30s him rise to prominence watch him
retire then re-enter the ring and see
him pass on his legacy as his health
starts to deteriorate this makes us
particularly attached to rocky and it
creates even more suspense during his
fights there's another reason that we
relate to rocky so much and there's
another reason that we find a story so
inspiring and that's the simple fact but
he's an underdog in almost every fight
he's in anytime rocky achieved some
semblance of power or authority that
stripped from him the plot even goes to
some contrivance is to accomplish this
so in Rocky 3 we learned that he can't
train like the champ to stay on top he
needs to be humiliated first stripped of
his mentor and then taken back to basics
just to regain the eye of the tiger just
so he can come back again and kick ass
in Rocky 5 rocky loses all of his
fortune thanks to the ill-informed
decision to leave the handling of his
finances to his mentally slow generous
brother-in-law in Rocky Balboa he's old
so Rocky is a hero who thrives against
the odds who shows that with dedication
and determination and a training montage
anything is possible and so in the
movies we interpret the various
opponents he faces as me and metaphors
for the struggles he's facing in real
life maybe it's confidence pride fear
nationalism or even cancer Creed is
perhaps the film to make this symbolism
the most clear and if you look more
closely at the philosophy
rocky series you can see that in many
ways this is a stoic parable stoicism is
the ancient Greek school of philosophy
that preaches the importance of realism
of recognizing the hardships of life and
embracing the reality that bad things
happen the world ain't all sunshine and
rainbows it's a very mean and nasty
place and I don't care how tough you are
it will beat you to your knees and keep
you there permanently if you let it
sterics believe that positivity can be
destructive that it's better to prepare
for hardship and even to try and thrive
when life gets hardest and this
philosophy is perfectly encapsulated in
Rocky's speech to his son and Rocky
Balboa you me or nobody is gonna hit as
hard as life but it ain't about how hard
you hit it's about how hard you can get
hit and keep moving forward how much you
can take and keep moving forward
that's how weird it is done in other
words life is tough so toughen up deal
with it and win anyway and when you
apply that philosophy to your workouts
it can be incredibly satisfying no
matter what's going on in your life no
matter how tough things get you can
choose to keep fighting when I go to the
gym I feel like I'm making that choice
when you have the worst day possible
and when you find it in your gut to
still hit the weights you're building a
kind of determination that's unstoppable
and then you can take on anything
those body said stop this spirit pies
whether or not Stallone intended to
infuse his story with stoic philosophy
is unclear but certainly the story was
inspired by real-life struggles and it's
definitely a parable for how he can
overcome those challenges
if you knuckle down Stallone's famous
inspiration for the character whist
Wepner a boxer who was a relative nobody
when he went up against Muhammad Ali in
1975 but he managed to go nearly all 15
rounds and then the less there was the
story of a guy who stood up against the
odds not only that a guy who could live
proudly with that personal victory and
the pride that came from that it didn't
even matter that he actually lost the
fight but the other inspiration for
Rocky Balboa is undoubtedly Stallone
himself everyone knows the story by now
Rocky was a struggling actor who'd even
been forced to sell his dog because he'd
hit on such hard times that's an
audition he happened to mention that he
also dabbled with writing and a producer
asked to see an example he presented
them with the draft for rocky and they
left it so much that they started
offering him huge amounts of money for
the rights
Stallone refused and remained steadfast
the only deal he'd accept was one where
he got to play the titular character he
even turned out $300,000 offer which is
roughly equivalent to a million dollars
today at a time when he only had a
hundred and three dollars in his bank
account
eventually the studio relented but they
gave the film minimal budget and
publicity they went on to win three
Academy Awards anyways and it made its
lead role into a megastar the rest is
history
like so many people Stallone does his
best work when the chips are down so
what you gonna do the next time life is
giving you a hard time
go get done
[Music]
round 12 begins virtually no one outside
thanks ton for watching guys hope you
found it very useful and interesting if
you did then please leave a like please
share it around and comment down below
maybe let me know what you find
inspiring about the rocky series or
better yet which is your favorite rocky
film mines either four or six I can't
quite make up my mind
subscribe if you'd like to see more like
this I've got ton more on the way on
brain training bodybuilding nootropics
productivity parkour fitness all the
usual stuff so if that sounds cool then
I'll see you next time thanks a ton for
watching once again and bye for now